en espagnol
C'est le résultat d'une attaque qui
vient de se passer dans la ville de
buissons que c'est l'un des
restaurants les plus importants du
ville une parmi tant d'autres s'ils étaient un peu
après 19 heures quand un
le missile est tombé exactement comme vous pouvez le voir
au restaurant c'était absolument
plein et ce que nous voyons dans ce
ce sont des scènes de terreur que nous avons
vu des blessés en sortir très sérieusement
ici ceux d'entre nous qui se sont vraiment rencontrés
c'est à dire que nous sommes vivants d'une certaine manière
miraculeusement, les horloges fonctionnent
ambulances Et en place c'est
absolument
détruit Cela a donc été l'un des
les nombreuses attaques qui ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
autour de la ville mais
très loin et ce missile tombe à un endroit
où il y avait des civils
et dans une ville qui évidemment aussi
Il y a beaucoup de soldats, c'est très proche
du front de bataille de Catalina